will cloth masks now be germ preservers
if they are stored in cold cars will
surface transmission be more likely with
germs kept alive through winter this way
so this question i think emerges from
the observation um
that uh people are keeping
masks in their cars you know and never
take them out and in some places
actually don't even take them out
uh to wear them they just live in the
car and then they'll put them on if they
absolutely have to if they're if they're
required to
which you know we we think that
coal is going to preserve the virus
and doesn't this effectively
um create an additional uh
an additional problem in terms of
effectively storing
the virus for activation
well a couple things one um
i think we have learned and somebody
took me to task for my use of the term
fomite
and in fact i looked it up to make sure
that i didn't have it wrong and i did
have it slightly wrong
the foamite is the surface itself rather
than the particle transmitted on the
surface oh is that right yep i didn't
know that
i hope i now have it right i'm going to
look it up while you're talking about
phone in any case
here's the point i think we know an
inanimate object or substance that is
capable of transmitting infectious
organisms from one individual to another
there it is yeah so i think that fomite
transfer is not
especially common with covet 19 or sars
kobe 2.
yeah and therefore the fact that you
will preserve
the virus in your car potentially on a
mask
doesn't increase the tendency to be
transmitted by a surface and therefore
if the
tendency wasn't very high yes this will
increase the duration over which it
could happen
but it might you know i mean a mask
if you have covid then your mask will
have covid
and it could last on there longer but
you're not going to infect you
so will somebody else be more likely to
be infected because the period of time
over which your mask is infectious goes
up yes arguably
not very high i wouldn't think the other
thing i want to know though
and this goes sort of into the biology
of cyrus kovi too
but i believe that the nature of
the um the viral
capsule here is
um not
that it is membrane-based and therefore
i wonder whether
a freezing might
you know freezing below some level would
damage it probably not but it could
um and b the other thing about the cars
is that you're going to get oscillations
you're going to warm your car up
it's going to be good and toasty as
you're driving around then it's going to
cool off then it's going to warm up that
kind of thing tends to be very hard on
something like a microorganism yeah the
car isn't just cold unless you're never
ever in it if you ever drive it you heat
it right up
right the chances that you said somebody
could get infected getting in your car
after it sat in the driveway for three
days is probably higher
in the winter but the
warm cool cycles are probably protective
if anything yeah that's good i hadn't
hadn't occurred to me i think that's
[Music]
right
you